[Musique]
ces images devrait en principe être
interdites
[Applaudissements]
car la loi juive la loi de la religion
est très stricte et interdit lors de
certaines cérémonies la reproduction des
images de fidèles
mais là aussi beaucoup de choses
changent et la contestation s'installe
[Musique]
des cérémonies sont celles de la roche à
Chanas le jour de l'an israélite qui
tombe environ à la fin septembre début
octobre
et cette fête célébrée par les
Israélites du monde entier vide tout
d'un coup un quartier de Paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce quartier de la rue des Rosiers dans
le marais qui est devenu le quartier
juif de Paris
tout est fermé ce jour-là les passants
sont rares chacun chez soi célèbre la
roche Hachana ainsi durant plusieurs
jours les rues du quartier vont rester
vides pendant aussi le Yom qui pour le
Jour du Jugement le jour de jeûne et
cela jusqu'à la fête du socote la fête
des cabanes commémorant la traversée du
désert après la fuite d'Egypte et que
l'on célèbre dans le quartier andressant
vraiment des cabanes avec des feuilles
et des branches dans les cours des
immeubles où les habitants des maisons
voisines toutes les familles vont se
retrouver pour les repas en prière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
quel moment le plus pittoresque
d'ailleurs c'est le moment des fêtes
l'acquisition qui sont des acquisitions
qui sont faites par tous ces Juifs de
tout Paris et de toute la province qui
vient dans le quartier qui vient chez sa
volaille vivante il se la fait égorger
par le
ravinateur je suis français j'y vais
deux fois par an j'y vais le jour de
l'an puis quand pardon
[Musique]
les autres samedi par exemple
[Applaudissements]
fête encore c'est le jour de l'an c'est
le jour du grand pardon et c'est la
Pâques juive ça s'arrête là
ça correspond à quoi de l'année
française le Nouvel An et le jour de le
grand pardon c'est
[Applaudissements]
milieu septembre
assez variable c'est aux environs de fin
septembre début octobre et la page juif
tombe environ avant ou après la pâte
chrétienne enfin c'est pas tellement
loin donc
si vous passez durant ces jours de fête
dans le quartier juif vous ne verrez
rien de tout ceci il faut passer les
portes cochères entrer dans les
immeubles et tout d'un coup découvrir un
monde qui vit en marge ces jours-là et
le jour du Shabbat par exemple le samedi
de toute la vie parisienne qui continue
à 100 mètres de là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
depuis hier soir 6h30
soit 7h15
on a jeûné et puis hier soir et bien il
y a une grande cérémonie à la synagogue
bien sûr avec des très beaux chants
habituels et en général même le soir je
crois que presque tous les Juifs qui se
sentent encore un peu Juifs viennent
assister à ça puisqu'en définitive n'ont
besoin ni de fermer les magasins de se
préoccuper plus que ça
donc c'est une fête qui tient à cœur à
presque tous les Juifs parce que tu
respectes quoi oui c'est la seule qu'il
reste toutes les synagogues font le
plein normalement on devrait pas rouler
en voiture ça c'est la loi c'est assez
difficile à Paris ou ailleurs alors on
compose un petit peu
nous oui on n'est pas des gens très très
pratique mais il y en a beaucoup qui ne
roulent pas du tout en voiture il y a
des gens qui rentrent à la synagogue à
9h du matin qui n'en bouge absolument
pas jusqu'à 7h15 du soir ma belle-mère
n'a pas bougé de la journée mon
beau-père non plus une fois même pas
sortis prendre l'air
il y en a beaucoup comme ça et au fond
le
tous les jours de fêtes le jour de
nouvelles en France tout est fermé aussi
c'est pareil on est pas très très pieux
on vit dans un monde moderne avec tout
un tas de conceptions différentes on se
sent extrêmement français puisque nous
sommes menés en France que nous avons
fait des études en France nos enfants
aussi nous vivons ici et si vous voulez
toutes ces coutumes nous semblent comme
un beau livre d'images souvent très très
jolie
[Musique]
et lorsque les cérémonies religieux se
terminent lorsque les jeunes s'achève
tout le monde se retrouve à l'épicerie
charcuterie ou au restaurant pour manger
des l'équerre par exemple des gâteaux ou
alors des carpes farcies du goulash et
aussi de la viande casher préparer selon
la loi religieuse les animaux ayant
d'abord été jugés propres à la
consommation toujours selon la loi
religieuse et puis saigner lentement non
pas avec
[Musique]
un poulet
mon dieu j'ai été élevé d'une certaine
manière qui faisait que j'étais quand
même assez attaché à
certaines traditions parce que il ne
venait pas à l'esprit que ça puisse être
autrement
et puis
ça a changé mais pourquoi vous avez
réfléchi parce qu'il s'est passé c'est
normal à partir d'un certain moment on
est on est quand même obligé et puis
beaucoup de choses qui ont joué
entre autres
entre autres le voyage en Israël que
j'ai fait cet été a quand même été pour
beaucoup je crois
pourquoi il vous semble que ici en
France les Juifs sont beaucoup plus
attachés à leur religion que en Israël
c'est normal je suis très attachée à la
communauté Israël mais pas par pas par
la religion par autre chose peut-être
par une certaine affinité d'esprit ou
par
certaines choses mettons par certains
côtés affectifs mais enfin c'est pas la
religion qui nous soute tous ensemble
que vous avez les amis
Israélites que vous avez pratiques la
religion ça dépend il y a des
pratiquants la majorité honnêtement de
mes amis de mes amis ne pratiquent pas
mais je connais d'autres gens qui
pratiquent qui ont mon âge les jeunes on
essaie de rajouter la religion juive
mais vous savez quand ils ont 15 16 ans
ils vont danser folklore qui a rude des
rosiers n'est pas
je l'aime pas tellement en fait je
préfère de ce côté là le folklore de
Jérusalem qui est beaucoup plus beau
dans le temps si vous voulez même bien
avant 10 ans c'était un quartier qui
était très typiquement polonais tout au
moins pas polonais mais islave toutes
les origines polonaises russes mais
yougoslave hongroise viennoise habiter
le quartier et
ces gens après la guerre ayant réussi un
petit peu dans la vie ont quitté plus ou
moins le quartier tout en conservant
certaines habitudes telles que celles de
venir chez nous au restaurant
charcuterie faire quand même leurs
emplettes et il y a eu cette évolution
des gens qui sont partis d'Afrique du
Nord qui sont en veulent étaient en
France et qui maintenant
habite le quartier car ils ont une
classe sociale qui leur permet pas si
vous voulez d'habiter d'autres quartiers
de payer les loyers plus importants dans
son famille extrêmement nombreuses
avant c'était vraiment le ghetto vous
comprenez maintenant je vous dis c'est
devenu la rue des six albums parce qu'il
y en a partout et cela parce qu'en
quelque sorte dans ce quartier se
maintient peut-être pour quelques temps
encore ce qui n'existe sans doute nulle
part ailleurs au monde du mois de cette
façon et qui est tout simplement une
certaine idée du respect des traditions
[Musique]